How could a lot love in the
background even shorter.
Like why the the eyes of the censors.
And i notices where there was this was.
On guard.
Build up on the g a r b u double t
and there. So.
Oh yes a v e r a s d o n c k.
Goes on to d. Yeah i'm john garber.
I am 58 years of age
and for the last ten years i've been
deeply involved in developing a
new model for the occupancy of rural land.
It's a village called the little clip
which we're very happy to call the solar
village.
In the name is peter verizon and
i've been in australia 20 years now
and i got your query in spirit in california
refined it through further studies
and enjoyment in the pacific and
got here around 14 years ago
and helps create the village
a blank list so often it is
because of this exactly
where i think about the
nearly 900 acres and with
35 k north west of lose me.
No so. Villain cliffs.
Is a privately owned strata
titled village on 908 as
35 k north west of lismore its physical
shape is three descending valleys.
Of about 300 acres.
These represent three main parts of the
village we have a north end which is very
very secluded
and alive with wildlife you have the centre
valley where most of the activity goes
on and we have the south and
which is a very highly developed
and for gannet growing it within
these three there is lay within
another steeple sort of value.
So from wherever you are situated billion
cliffs is a magnificent view of the
actual cliff and bill in the flat top.
So we live in a valley that is bounded
on one side by a flat topped cliff.
Every team bird
and on the other side some rolling open
land here till we reach the mackellar
ranges are going steep brains
is good and timber is.
Popular.
Yeah the village would have around 80
different homes or structures of meat.
Maybe 70 would be occupied.
And so you turned and 15 lots
and all we certainly in selling it
up took a proper balance between the
requirements of nature and human
requirements and economic requirements and.
We made a formula 30 30 30 each sell you'd
have a third of the property is under
private control for your own gardens
and home about a third of it is
controlled with your neighbours
or your forestation or for some economic
activity like orchard ing ourselves
and a third is set aside as a wildlife
area specifically to render trees back in
when the koalas back in and still.
You know this is where we differ from
most other communities there is no
philosophical or religious or political
kind of ties here this was a village
that was designed by a visionary
guy from nimbin terry magee
it was put together by the legal
side of things to put together by.
Tony poor got oh well no lismore solicitor
and it was put together
as a multiple occupancy
and based on the draft of the multiple
occupancy code did come out a few years
before and
that allowed a certain portion
of the land to be ours
and individually with
and the rest held in common
and we'll come back to this later on
however that's the way it was put together
and from the very word go.
We had experienced an awful lot of
trouble with councils settling in.
It seemed to be the state government
saying yes you can do things like this
and the council saying well you can do it
but not really in our backyard in our
backyard even though they had given the
development approval had been given.
And everything was being done.
I'll let peter talk a while for about
that side of the problems with council.
They're virtually a classic
response and they could be study.
They won't be the same we were encouraged
them to hills by by state government.
We were trying to be pushed out
of the hills by local government
and federal government paid
for it all but a whole mess.
It's cost the government a lot of money
and it is basically it's a reflection of
a lack of integration on the level of
government and that is state governments
or the need for people to settle in the
hills to change clapped out farms into
organic paradises to
change been employed used
and to people who built their
own homes in their own assets
and local government didn't want to do
the show in one fact what they did.
A souness as you know i rephrased
it meant a differently
when we did receive the approval.
The major died shortly in that period
and in between the the final lodging of
the application bureaucracy put a request
for they want to 20 year bridge which is
going to cost something like five million
dollars and then said no one can
move on and mr. bridge is build
and so they put as a midi outside the law.
We were illegal occupants of the
land by by design by local council
and from there on it went onto a parade
or a show raid really off of needling
and pastoring
that beggars description from having to
put every tree on the property onto a map
and to what slope the tree would
stand on of what size it would be
and fire hydrants every two metres
and. It was there was a madhouse.
They made us put $25000 in
engineering reports on bits of land
that you know only and
when i look back on those days
the only thing i find incredible
and hard to believe is that
so many of us stuck it out
and out of the very first 20 people who
landed here we still have 15 of them.
And three of the others come back regularly
wishing they hadn't sold up. So it.
It did two things for us. It taught
us how to handle bureaucracy.
It taught us
that sometimes confrontation is necessary
but more than anything else it world
it is together as a group of people
because we've all come from
different walks of our lives.
You know peter had come from brisbane i'd
come from rocky other people many people
had never been on the land and we
were here we because we were illegal.
We couldn't make a row
people were trudging up
and down hills carrying buckets of water.
You know that was quite frightening
and finally i suppose we we
started to feel ourselves in fact
and we started doing a bit of arguing
and doing a bit of construction
and we brought things to a head.
We've had really 10 years of problems with
with local government it was only really
a couple of individuals within the
bureaucracy of the lismore council.
We brought things to such a
head one stage in the game
that person threatened to take us into
court and we said we'd love to see.
Because we publicly he defamed him.
But we didn't we just told the truth about
that time we were called feral youmans
that's the name for it and i know
that i worked with integral rock
to see at that time there was
and then we had feral youmans
and the whole notion of a fourth level
of government which we were here.
We wanted to empower ourselves to make the
decisions about iowa love area about our
roads and not get each and every
decision of local government so
that whole process was alien to the
average bureaucrat thought that that was.
It was a communist. Yes. Bred
to us it wasn't good. To us.
It always was the essence you.
Well you must you must make a new
system which both has capitalism
and communism in it into a numeric.
I myself i'm a green economist and i
get very upset if i see to divide
and rule ethics
that is being done by the major players
which as you are either a commie
or your capital. Grows as a matter of
fact we have these urges are selves.
When it comes to making a stand on our car
or our land you believe you have your
individual rights your preservative if you're
a capitalist. When it comes to the point
that you need a right from a neighbor
certainly you become a communist. You know.
We've got a bit of both and and
i can well see from the eyes.
You do baroque to see that time
that a group of people settling land a
big group a big group of people. Yes.
Creating a and independent
and burnley controlled village was
frightening most frightening.
Yeah i can see that while they were
thinking of going to be hordes of them.
Yeah you know like on the road if we we
thought we were one of the first of many
there was real fears at the time that it
was going to be a swing in the electorate.
Because of these new settlers
being politically on the spectrum
or something like that and in
fact in that actually happened.
The land's released policy of councils today
is based on bringing it up to the land
that brings polluted desirable people.
Then it's never stated like that.
It's just a fact of life
and it's not corruption that's
just how the government works.
Our western system we point at asia saying
those inside look each system has their
own in below the ks so let's get on
what means. Ok we're talking about now.
I suppose 1980 to we got
our approval in september.
Some people moved on straight away.
I didn't actually move on and
till october eighty three.
Because i felt the place
was falling to pieces.
Nothing was at me so i came here
and started to build my house
and within a month three other
houses were going up up until
that time no one was
doing council came round
and stuck these things on our notice
on our doors stop working immediately
and all this bullshit and in
fact they came up here once
and he stood here for about 15
minutes and we were all working away
and no one took the blind but a
notice i finally called out to me
and he said you've got to stop this work.
I said yes my friend when the
roof is on and we've moved in
and it's finished our stop and he got
the same kind of response elsewhere.
It came to a head and they agreed then
to do what the agreement had always been
that we could be a bit of a staged
development we get this we do that we get
that we do that we had 17 conditions here.
I could explain it and
when here you know the motivation
in the minds of the principals was
to to create a model
that can be used by those millions of
unfortunates that are without work
or with our vision. We're living in
a country in a system world wide.
That's still favor for us
pesticides and trucks.
Farming
and it has depopulated a real population
from you know like 20 per cent your
farmers to it is now only a few per cent
and those people have an essence gone
to the city and are full of an employed
and we're trying to reverse that and saying
you've got to go into organic farming.
You've got to go into high labour intensity
we must start making labour lovely
again and gardening us healthier
gardening is good for you.
So we were always in that mode of mind.
We had to provide something
that can be used easily
and i think ultimately that's the fight
that was on the height
behind the scenes is
that the establishment for
whatever reason was not ready
to embrace a model
that now is so sorely needed because
how do you settle people on the land.
It didn't work as a multiple occupancy
because the moment to emma was created the
right to withdrawn from it.
You couldn't get a telephone you couldn't
get a first home owners grant you're a
you were a non-citizen in fact you could
be sprayed on by the air because you were
only one farm goes fast and
people didn't exist. Ok.
We became rural residents feel we could
well maybe we should just talk a little bit
more about that. What actually happened.
We've been having all this trouble
and we'd agreed on a stage development
they would give us 10 building permits for
people who were living in bad
conditions here if we did this much of
the same we did that they gave it a few
more did this they gave it so that way
that went through but as we
were coming towards the end of
that one day the planner of the
day a guy called peter rangers
sent us a letter and.
This is to be in 84 85 when the multiple
occupancy code actually came out and
when it came out due to influences
from bodie farm and diamond under the.
He was saying this is all wrong.
Shouldn't be all the land should be held
in common like you know we can all sit
here
and think about buddha together every night
so they actually stuffed up the multiple
occupancy card
and i'm not blaming them they just did
what they thought was the right thing
but
that my we got a letter from this planner
saying within the terms of the multiple
occupancy code you are an illegal
subdivision because we had our own internal
certificate for our to haters
and he said i would suggest
you stay your certificates up
and forget about the boundary.
So that just got right up
my nose for a kickoff.
And there was no leadership at
that moment one leadership group had collapsed
over the failure of the development
plan which was to finish the road
if it didn't get finished and
that development group felt pieces
but some of those people pop forward
and i got involved and we created
what we called illegality crew
and we started with a massive letter
writing campaign to every bureaucrat
and every politician in
federal and state spheres
and writing the most heart rending letters
about our situation here we'd put our
lives in which we had it was all the
truth and now after four years.
We're told we're an illegal subdivision.
So it came to a head actually the day
before the labour government got kicked out
in new south wales one of the last act bob
carr did as environmental minister was
sign a document converting this land
from rural to rural residential
and he threw it right back into the lap
of the lismore city council said right
we've ruled we've rees owned the land
and now you issue them
with some sort of title.
So we ended up with the strata title.
It's not the best way
of doing our community
and it's been a been very
very expensive for us
but as i say we've had a very strong
core group here right from the word go.
And 85 per cent of the people who
have come in since then have
kind of joined that vision.
So we've been extremely lucky we had a
few dissenters every community does
everywhere in the world
but we have very few
and we've just taken a further step forward
now by getting this government money
and undertaking certain things.
So it was the strength of that core
group and it was the first four
or five years with all this
cobblers we had you know right.
Very early in the piece
before anything else.
Some neighbors around here
and some who live nowhere near here on
public money through legal aid took to
lismore city council to court to say
that this shouldn't be allowed to happen
or is a piece of shit in the creek led
by a guy who works for the founder so
security is very scared to having social
security recipients moving next to his
farm. Yes.
So it went down to the environmental
court the land environmental court
and diamond jim was the judge and after
about a three nine months or something.
He finally got the shits didn't he just
said look he said bring this case to an end
tomorrow is i'm sick of it
but almost every one of these for you
know it almost killed it nearly killed us
nearly killed us and they did it all
on legal aid cost us forty five grand.
Eighty four. And i think eighty four.
Sorry and i say to you three three eighty
three eighty three thousand eighty two.
The beginning of the year and you know
we got our approval in september.
And final approval in september 80 to
this was in january. Eighty three.
This was the first thing
we had to end counter.
However as i say that there
were about 10 people involved.
They had time to build a group. Yes
it was wrong girl a core group.
So the adversity was good for them.
I tell you bout how i was living.
So i've been were i was well
i've come down from rocky
but nothing was happening here.
So i had a job to do in lismore
and i was living indonesian
and i come over every weekend and
come over board meetings and stuff
and i could sense. Nothing
was happening and i.
We knew by then the court case
was on i went down as a witness
and i said to my wife
could you stand living
in a tent. Bearing in mind.
She was 53 years of age you know we
bought a marquee tent which we still use
at bill and cliffs on functions and things
that was out there where my car is.
And i our son jason and his friend richard
and our daughter zoe lived in that tent.
We had hot food and we
had a fridge in there
and so he went to school looking clean every
day shoes to bathe in the wheelbarrow
it. We're just about got
ready to have our roof up
and i had a drunken
accident in my motor car.
I turned my motor car over
and i do it was a big beautiful toyota land
cruiser i'd always intended to sell it
to finish the house but it
took me about three months
or four months to get the money
together to get the repairs done so
that i could sell it.
So yeah it took us 10 months
and in 10 months we had this locked up
here was ready to move to no wall just the
roof on the wall. We had
our big tent under here.
And my young daughter had
a little tent over here
and we used to sleep up in the lot. Then
we got that one down and gradually.
Well two years.
Basically we had basic house
we just improved a little bit.
I was just moving in from existing executive
post in brisbane doing an opening
night apartment
and i really wanted to get away from
anything to do with civilization so i walked
in buckets for years and i was more
interested in a sitting in a rain
and sitting inside.
I'm still building my house after
10 years getting there slowly
but i've done lots of other things.
Oh yeah i've put my total time here.
That's a different. Carry on world
the thing is how did you do it.
I i i think you got to have a certain
philosophical foundation to do it.
You must either be a grassroots worshipper
that wants to you know improve nature
or have some such compassion to
actually do it and i believe now
that land should be settled not like like
like i did i don't think it is for public
consumption i think it's not many can do
it in fact that's one of many people are
doing it is beautiful
and it certainly made me love the
country more than i ever could.
You know stepping away from
that cage of civilization out there
amongst the ticks in the mosquitoes and
and the snakes
but nowadays i favour a mode where you
have a little cabin to start with
and work on from there but
therefore can be accessed by a.
Less adventurous. Started. Yes.
There was a divorce several different
philosophies i think operating at the time i
don't think any of us are really aware what
all the philosophies were prevalent in
people's minds we service soon
they were all but the same
but there weren't there was a very strong
group of people who were just want to
build a beautiful organic garden and
there were those people who are into.
Celebrating the low cost of the land.
And belinda own home the home builders
and their distinct lifestyle.
The home builders and it was a
nice home and rudimentary gardens
and the gardens had mostly beautiful
gardens and smaller cabins.
There also was a sufficient large
group of people who were the
if you wish the outcasts of a modern
society who run into trouble emotionally
mentally or financially in that
big thing called the system
and came to push for refuge very much still
a part of our lifestyle is to actually
have compassion for those those people.
Nevertheless
that creates problems of its own because
you have to start thinking for people like
that after you've got it and projecting
much as a leadership to make
and part of it. So one of the things
that was the most important to me i
find myself shifting from a very
well-paid
and satisfactory position
in government to a non-paid
position which i was very proud
and happy with actually transforming
the world in a little way in time
and making a contribution to something
you know i think that the main battle
that we have now in is trying to make a
sorrow to reassess the meaning of what were
you see and we have been successful
leader in a couple of minor ways.
Already we we have made various
groups understand the only
day to day judge work if you get paid by
but you know there's a lot of work done
which people don't get paid for we do a lot
of work here voluntarily we maintain
our own roads and all that and.
So yeah that's what we're working on now
is trying to get a reassessment of the
meaning of words like to say
something there at the time
that we are starting maybe a year
or two after another development try
to sway here called melbourne springs
and they were very orderly very order they
were calling for carpenters new cancer
plumbers there were really trying to
structure a model society whereas we didn't
have no such choice we just took anybody
you know want to come into effect
melbourne springs failed because of all
organisation where we succeeded because in
the end i became the statistic
planning for this village.
John became the trainer
for the village the
or the grower can you're going
to grow over the village dick
and the machine member came the.
The road builder for the village
and strangely enough in a lot of people
who thought they had a skill in one way.
In fact coming to live here has developed
a skill it another way we have a
shoemaker here who really wants
to be a bad guitar maker.
But he makes shoes you know
fearful issues like iran so.
I just made a threat is known
when i realized we were different from the
other communities in a way is now coming
to fruition in a true sense not just
legally because of the documentation
but because we had learned to
get a so much over this period
and found solace in you for the strength
and we acted like a company more and more.
Finally we could sit down amongst ourselves
and saying what the hell is going on.
Why are all of us sitting here being
basically kept in poverty by.
The lack of work being available here
we are positioned in a place here.
How do we go of it. We took stock
of our skills from society
and those skills we developed ourselves
in the interim like mud brick building
and let glassing
and stand sort of cementing the sergeant
bushwalking dam building all these things
and we went to get it and
we looked at our place here
and we said look we are living here on
a national park quality bit of land
and we are selves our rehabilitating
into a world heritage reserve.
We've got the infrastructure to
become teachers of this guilt
and we've got the skills and we built
the teaching around our common skills
and with the taking stock of a village
which i think is unique in australia
but actually this fourth level
government looking at itself
and saying what can we do years
to solve australia's problems
and here close by now we're not getting
into the commercial development stage we're
starting to talk about common growing we're
time to do this just in this hall which
is happening here. In the getting to know.
Major building programs on right now.
And by the end of next year we will have
completed by the middle of this coming.
Ninety three in one year we would have
completed two major buildings i don't know
if you saw the one wrapped up in black
plastic that's going to be the most
magnificent. To building on three levels
and are the building is quite magnificent
and that's all done on voluntary labour.
So.
People do work. Now.
So. Much.
Welter has been a major part. If bill and
chris could not a billion kids. Sorry.
You know.
Okay without we don't i don't consider
welfare welfare ice arms to the old school i
believe that social security.
So we have about a third of the
people here who have their
own money from one source
or another about a third of our
people are on some sort of pension
and we have about a third
of the people unemployed
that has been the way this was
designed this village was designed for
low income earners to come here and go
down and that was based on the fact
that they were on the dole and they
could get the first homeowners.
Grant and things like that.
Now we've got no worries about
that because we have a hundred fifteen
families living in this valley
that couldn't maintain one farmer
and three hundred cows
out of those people the
ones
that are here now are virtually
becoming they're on the verge of
wanting to earn class something and
yes. One of the reasons why the was.
So security dependent.